what we are covering in this lesson is
number one this idea of thinking about
the derivative and only thinking about
it geometrically now what's the opposite
of that we know how to work out
derivatives using algebra right if I
gave you something like say X to the
power of five we should know how to
differentiate that even without putting
any rest it's gonna be five X to the
four you didn't need to know what X to
the power of five looked like you could
just sort of think about the numbers in
the address is fine and we could give
you a product or we could give you a
function of a function X minus one all
to the power of five and you would
handle that new problems right but what
you're looking at here and on that piece
of paper there is a function and you
don't know anything about its equation
which means you can't use all of your
power rule quotient rule product rule
all that kind of thing because you got
an algebra to deal with right now before
we get stuck into how to actually do
this I want to make sure there's some
justification for this right why do we
care about thinking about derivatives
visually well hopefully you guys can
make out sorry I cannot move this screen
so it's over here a bit easier for y'all
to make out especially right here but um
sometimes you'll get a graph right
there's some physical phenomena that you
want to understand like the growth of a
population right or for instance the
spread of a disease inside someone's
body and you don't get an equation for
that
right you just have data you just take
measurements you met you collect blood
you put them in the machine it's like oh
yeah this is what we think of the t-cell
counts at the moment and you track it
over time and then you've got this graph
what can you do with this if we want to
understand how it's changing calculus is
still the tool that we use but all that
power rule question rule all that
doesn't help us so now when you have a
look at something like this pen in hand
and your ruler as well how could we go
for an object like this you can see this
first set of axes it's the y axis there
what we're going to graph beneath it
just look down it's very small but
hopefully you notice that's not the y
axis there that's the y dash this is the
derivative we're going to do the first
derivative of this and I'm actually
going to do it again as you'll see
that's why there's so many spots there
let's turn off my Wi-Fi we don't need
that okay so here's the first thing I'd
like you to do
have a look at this graph and have a
think about in terms of calculus where
are the most interesting or important
places on this graph a place where you
can maybe tell me something yet go ahead
ok so fantastic let's all mark in I
count 1 2 & 3 spots where our graph our
function intersects with the x axis so
we call these guys the X intercepts
right there's three so if you had to
make a guess we don't have the equation
but what would you think what would you
guess the equation of this thing would
be like Bement you've got three X
intercepts yeah very good X cubed and
then some other terms after it it's not
going to be an x squared or something
like that because this is not a parabola
right it's not going to just be like
five exercise that because not a
straight line yeah so we know we're
expecting now when it comes to calculus
it turns out that these particular spots
are actually not that important to us
it's more about how the graph changes
for example I'm gonna mark in these two
spots here do you see the spots I'd
encourage you to mark them on your graph
as well these two spots are really
important when it comes to calculus they
have a special name have you guys
encountered the name of this yet yeah
what you got yeah we're gonna work out
we are gonna work out some tensions
actually you're anticipating my second
half of the lesson when you work out the
tangents for these two spots what's
special about the tangents at both of
these locations they're gonna be can you
do with your arm what would the great
what would the tangents look like
hopefully you can put keep a trammel
parent put in a plier there we go right
the tangent and you can actually see
don't draw this because it's not
actually all we want but you could draw
a horizontal line
that's not very horizontal let me try
that again I'm gonna cheat and do this
hey Gary that's super horizontal right
so can you see at that spot and also
down the bottom here you would have a
horizontal tangent right so we call
these stationary points does that phrase
ring a bell
stationary points it's as if you're
moving through this graph and at that
top spot and at that bottom spot you
just so stay still for a minute
stationary okay so with your ruler in
hand now you can actually draw something
what I'd like you to do is a vertical
line vertical line
all the way from our stationary points
down to the graph or the plane beneath
so if this is what it's going to look
like let me make it a bit thicker so you
can see I'm gonna draw this vertical
line all the way down so use a ruler and
hopefully you can see it extending from
my stationary point all the way down to
this x-axis down here I'm going to do it
for the first stationary point and I'm
gonna do it for the second ok now we
pick these guys out because if the
tangent like we said is horizontal what
would the value of the gradient be if
your tangents horizontal it's zero right
because you're not rising you're not
going up you're not dropping you're not
going down so you've got a gradient and
that's what this next graph is about
you've got a great in of zero so that's
why you can see my lines they extend
down to what's this line represent
that's y equals zero right or y dash to
equal zero I should say so I'm gonna put
an X here and here this is where my
gradient I think of my original function
and where its gradient is 0 its 0 here
and it's also 0 up there you're
following with me is that ok so that's
why I've got 0 here 0 here alright for
my next part if you've got colors on you
they'll be handy but not necessary I'm
gonna look back at this original graph
and I want to think about at what places
is the graph increasing going up and at
what places is it decreasing going down
okay and I want us to mark it out like
this I'm gonna give you two examples
right see this spot here this part of
the graph ok over there on the left hand
side increasing or decreasing it's
increasing right we always read from
left to right it's going up ok so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to put
a plus sign there and I invite you to do
the same because the gradient of an
increasing part is positive is that ok
gradient of an increase in part of the
graph is positive so that's my plus sign
okay I'm going to shift over to red can
someone point out to me where's a place
just one spot where the graph is going
downward decreasing well you reckon yeah
yeah fantastic so in between here and is
that here that you said yeah yeah in
fact the whole section there its
decreasing isn't it going down so in
fact we can put more than just one minus
sign negative gradient I could like you
said put in negative signs all along
here because the gradient all the way
along in that section will be negative
okay I'm going to pause for a minute
you've got a whole graph there I've only
given you a little bit I want you to
indicate with some pluses and some
minuses where do you see the part of the
graph that's increasing that's a plus or
decreasing that's a minus draw as many
as you can fill up the whole thing now
let's have a think about it in a second